weißt du nicht ich habe eine verzögerung
jetzt fällt erstmal in st jetzt fällt
erstmal runter der wird dann von den
pisten wieder hoch geschleudert dann
fällt er woanders hin
und dann fällt er auf nur auf nur anders
und dann löst er daraus antriebs
außerdem wird ein pfeiler spencer
geschossen und der geht dann darauf und
dann darauf und dann wirst du und dann
explodiert alles
hallöchen freunde und herzlich
willkommen in der 35 folge der today
show zusammen mit mir und kontrast mit
mir und den einzel und unser heutiger
gast ist diese medien
hallo hühnchen für die zukünftigen gäste
müssen jetzt ein haus bauen damit jedoch
werkzeuge haben weil sonst schafften dir
nur solche häuser wie das da graf mag es
wenn wir es aus nein also huhn lp ist
heute zu gast sein - nur kanal schon
gibt es eigentlich cross cup sein
mikroskop oder sehen kann ich mitreden
aber der hat erfahrung der gibt sich
gerade um
also ich finde ich helfe mir einfach ein
lp noch nicht das ist eure chance
erstellten lp so hühnchen ich zeig dir
doch mal das ist jeder jemand heute noch
um apps stellt und 100 abonnenten darauf
innerhalb von eines innerhalb eines
tages kommt das ist jetzt mal die frage
gehen den würde ich auch abonieren hotel
palazzo ausstand abonnieren lp ich auch
einfach nur der werhahn lpr stellt er
schreibt es bitte in die kommentare
unter hohen lp oder gab es hunderte
charme und das wort gelöscht gibt es
noch gar nicht wie das hier ausschaut
das sakko es hat noch heute einem
rundgang auf der insel einmal dritter
schreiben wenn wir 100 also 100 ps ja
hier aber der hat halt
na ja er ist ein kanal wurde von youtube
gelöscht und man der name das ist was
ganz besonders eignet auf den namen den
namen dürfte trotzdem jetzt verwenden
also lebt und schreibt dann als unep in
die kommentare
hallo und dann licon all den kommentar
und dann abonniere ich hunderte sofort
machen kommentar schreiben und wohnen
wir lassen dich mal da wenn du willst
einfach nur darum ist übrigens 100 ps
bruder das ist 100 p2 ist ein zweiter
kanal fertig sein bruder arrangiert und
ja also wir werden heute ein
zusammenhang
wir haben uns gedacht wir laden jetzt
keinen ofen großen geldgeilen youtuber
ein sondern wir machen das mit hohen lp
weil er fürchte dass wir im 10.000 euro
geben aber wir wollten nur 9000 aber wir
haben's konnten sich einigen darum ist
jetzt 100 peter maffay dazu eigentlich
mit frank war dass du der der hat gesagt
dass der uns 1000 gibt dafür dass er
dann
zu gast sein darf aber nicht angenommen
weil das macht so was machen wenn ich
bis besteht und welche müssen wie kann
er auch gut sein und da kann man sich
bestechen wenn das leck oder irgendein
kanal wobei ecke kommt der namen gelesen
habe allein schon krank
was soll das denn mit dass er deutsch
oder was das rücken runtergelaufen
ersetzt war war ich dachte schon dass
die hunderten seriöser name gewesen wäre
wie video oder so denn dann hätte ich
auch gesagt ich sage klar wie 100 ps
oder 100 ps ist die seriosität in person
also ein huhn das ist einfach
unglaublich und krank dass da denke das
ist so ein hustenreiz anfall postings
das ist richtig das richtige tut mir
richtig in der seele weh wenn ich so
namen hören denken wow das sieht und das
ist das was uns solche leute überhaupt
anschreiben weiße meinen die müssen doch
die muss auch bewusst sein dass wir
keine chance haben bei uns großen
geniale youtuber und zu gast zu sein
richtig dem ist nichts mehr hinzuzufügen
und wie du schon prophezeit ast ich hab
hunger hunger hunger haben hunger und
ich mache sofort weiter mit erfahren als
wir wollten ja heute eigentlich uns um
das stadthaus kümmern
ach ja das hatte sind dass wir heute nur
mit huhn lp was zusammen machen nämlich
wollten wir endlich mal der staat haus
bauen
danke dass ihr mich so schnell
wiederholt das thema echt nett von dir
das habe ich am anfang auch schon gesagt
dann hast du mich zuerst über dich
verliebst du warst nur ein hersteller
der läufer mitläufer mitläufer und so
schlechter erhitzter auf ein kart fahren
wir gerade erde hinter dem haus von lp
mit cash das echte das schönste haus
fiel sogar noch schöner als parks
eigentlich ja das stimmt
da will ich auch es hat es hat einfach
stil es hat clusters diaz hat 1.4
features drin spark hätte sich natürlich
schon vorher die 1.4 runterladen können
wenn er da ein bisschen private jetzt
1.3 gebaut
ja da egal als der schönste park ist ein
bett das hab ich auch gebaut
wer von denen es muss ja schön sein ach
nee ich dachte dass wir offen jetzt
stehe ich an seinem fenster oben und her
was zu schaden hhg gut gehen wir planen
und bauen danach dann dieses komische
haus ja das erste mal hingehen
übrigens erwartet da jetzt kein kein
weißes haus was wir da hin bauen so von
wegen sondern schwarzes höhe erwartet da
kein weißes haus oder buckingham palace
was wir da hin sondern eher so eine
garage
nein nein gibt es wieder
wieder geht mir wieder gibt mir wieder
das unfair dass sich und ist drauf alter
wirklich bescheuert
ich habe sogar keinen einzigen
wer das angegangen wenn man in den ofen
was rein getan hätte ich glaub nicht das
ist sodann wie eine fackel der ofen
leuchtet ja nur es aber irgendeine
methode gibt und mit einem an wenn ofen
angeht irgendwie redstone auszulösen
irgendso einer schaltung das dann weißt
du warst einer bei dir und in die
kommentare geschrieben hat wenn einer
bei dir in die kommentare schreiben
den absturz war ganz bei uns du könntest
dich erreichen bei con crafter und das
willst der auch und also ich versuche
das grab wieder aufzufassen ist
geschrieben hat dann ja mach doch mal
bei dir eine schallplatte hinterachse
contra eine schallplatte hin also
konkret darauf treten dann machst du dir
ganz ganz untätig rats nur bis zur craft
den kleinen spricht da alles in die luft
und dann den crafter warum explodiert
was bei ihm wenn du wenn er doch bei dir
ist und dann hinter dir bestimmt nicht
die schuld geben und ich schreibe dann
so drunter gut dass du das nicht
öffentlich gemacht hast du da so will
jetzt kann ich das auch machen habt ihr
doch verboten das was du solltest dich
meine kommentare also schlägen du liegst
du mitnehmen
er sollte besser selber angst mich
vielleicht ausziehen und so sind
zugleiter ausziehen bitte noch weiter
älter ist übrigens kein skin bei mir du
ab wäre alles aber blöd was bei mir ins
kinn aber die sieht nicht schön aus
wieso hast du überhaupt meint ihr team
bei tnt wieder das hier ja damit ich
habe ein feuerzeug und tnt mechanismus
rettungsmechanismen rettungsschirm nicht
muss rettungsmechanismus
das hast du nicht während der aufnahme
gebaut
ich halte das werde auf eine gewollte
anschauen den hat gar nicht auf den
server natürlich auch die haufen haben
wir heute heißt dass der hund fand ich
eine platte hingelegt und damit wird
mein haus gewinnst was auch hier vorne
du kommst du nicht mehr raus kommt da
nicht mehr raus alles kann man mit ihr
geschlafen
danach kommt der weihnachtsmann mit dem
tmt
los gehts zur hinaus willst es gute
nacht zum nikolov wünscht man sich
nichts lieber felix doch einheiten und
der wunschzettel ist kein bestellzettel
das kenne ich das kenn ich auch wünschen
kann man sich alles ob er kommt kann ist
eine andere sache muss eine rüstung
nachdem ich an
wir wollten starthaus bauen stattdessen
bist du hier
denn angefangen am boden ja ich muss
gerade schallplatten und feuerzeuge
holen ja ja ja sag mal schallplatten
nicht mehr die betritt kloppen fahrer
ach so ja
hast du jetzt machst
auch wäre sofort mein herz noch sofort
auf ihr sofort auf was machst du denn da
eigentlich steht
nein warum denn was würde eigentlich
alter du provozierst doch immer dann
fragt euch an das repariert da war am
anfang auch ein kapitän ich wollte es
nun wieder so bauen wie es war
ich habe da jetzt ist die du hast da
irgendwas hin gebaut und eine
schallplatte wolltest du drauf machen
das heißt nicht schallplatte sondern ihr
scheiß dritte platzverweis ist meine
sachen eingesammelt dieser schlingel
könne sofort kicken kann man oben ist
habe ich aus versehen anstatt einem / 17
geschrieben player gründen wie frauen er
freiwillig geleistet dass nur noch mit
der hohen lp2 der logik 200 übrigens auf
den mod die mod dass man ihn nicht sieht
wenn man tab gedrückt hält der liste
weil der so an der kampagne auf servern
wenn das amt mail fotos machen muss und
man hat einfach uns an der cup auf
public server metall einmal nicht mehr
da nein ich hatte sechs lkw dann hatte
ich 2xlc 1
hast du dich überhaupt immer meinem haus
du da bist echt selber schon dauernd
durch mein haus drüen ich greife ich nie
an aber ich mache nie was und bei dir
ich habe dass er jetzt auch sein können
wann wird's mal langsam anfang hier kam
ein erfolg sagt ja dass schaaf mit
bestimmten fünf minuten jetzt zwischen
10 minuten hier und haben bisher was man
geschafft nix du hast mich getötet
ich hab dich liebevoll vom leben
verteidigt
das obst gesagt wird was schon wieder
angefangen das will ich begreifst alte 8
ich habe eine bessere rüstung alles
mögliche von daher gefragt na ja gut so
jetzt bei mir im haus
jetzt bauen wir ein haus wo sollen das
im erdreich mich auch soll das noch
hinführen niveau soll das haus überhaupt
hilfreich
irgendwo wo es nicht so schön ist muss
nicht schön ist sogar am besten wo es
relativ zentral ist zwischen uns können
wir das immer unseren kleines linken er
aber hier ist das zu eng alles wird sein
ist hier zu eng
das weiß auch mal mit dem mit dem links
hier mit dem kiesweg gut verbunden sein
können werden haben machen tun ja
deutsch vielleicht hier so so über dem
haus weil über deinem keller teil
charaktere arena hast du die
schallplatte hingelegt das keine
schallplatte ist eine tritt platte okay
sie lässt nichts aus das ist weißt du
nicht ich habe eine verzögerung im
kreistagssaal darunter der wird dann von
den pisten wieder hoch geschleudert dann
fällt er woanders hin
und dann fällt er auf nur auf nur anders
und dann löst er daraus antritt außerdem
wird ein feuer und explodierten und der
geht dann darauf und dann darauf und
dann wirst du und dann explodiert alles
ist so und wo bauen wir das jetzt ja
wenn das irgendwas haushalt saniert das
material das aus such dir was auf eine
position nicht erst mal kurz die schaffe
das fallout video des chefs kannst du
bis leiser machen ja ok wat ich mache
ein anderes kreta bitte vielleicht
diskret esskastanien sehe ich die stirn
treibt
ja ich weiss nicht die bäume wackeln
hier schon richtig vor weil sie so angst
haben dass ihr sohn ein der dena kommt
mit seiner lange axt das war zwar
deutlich mit lange axt egal wo bist du
rennst erklärt hast du denn es war ganz
eindeutig also ist hier so wegmachen
kombi mahnel einfach weg weg du kannst
den baum kümmern
ok ich kann nichts anderes okay okay
okay ist okay hast überhaupt gravel
gravel ja ich glaub ich hab noch liegen
sehr gut ich gerade mache einfach so ein
weg jetzt hab ich mal ein paar von
diesen komischen blättern alter geht er
schnell mit sondern schon sagen wir
machen hier unten das stadthaus hin
ja das sieht gut aus denn dann der weg
vom starthaus wird dann richtig der geht
ein solcher import zu meinem haus und
könig sitzt und links daneben der
bedienstete hier mit seinem kleinen
eisenbahn waggon
schön das ist
skurrile kunst ja richtig kasse das
gemacht hätte wird so auch sagen hier 20
milliarden gemälde
ach ja und all die gesagt haben diddy
diddy diddy die knöpfe erfüllen keinen
sinn
johanne sie sind aber vielleicht schön
welche weil hier im haus an meine tür
ist bringt gerade in verbindung mit
schön hast du schon mal die anzahl an
stein gesehen hast du schon mal anzahl
die wir die anzahl an vale wolle gesehen
wer sich anzahl an fenstern gesehen das
badezimmer ist hygienisch die hygiene
ist gut
jeder ist sauber das war
das war 100 g man nun lp bist du deinen
namen geändert wird was ich alles klar
du hast den mp3 hast und den black ops 2
auch und alles aber das ist mit so was
ihr kompensieren musste für gegen
wehrlose mitbürger grauenhaft ich hab
die drei miteinander getötet der streak
ob mal hier liegt ein irons wort darf
das wohl nehmen wie man an man da so
wartet kabul und links vom kranke kloten